eggsy I saw in you what someone once saw
in me something that can't be taught the
makings of a casement being a Kingsman
is more than the clothing we wear all
the weapons we bear it's about being
willing to sacrifice for the greater
good I hope you're ready for what comes
next
[Music]
and now the end is near and so I face
the final curtain my friend I'll say it
clear I'll state my case of which I'm
certain
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
[Music]
the harder yet the book I think we
should do you the favor of conversing in
English yes so tell me HC what do you do
I work for Kingsman the tailless nice
[Music]
[Applause]
I must say you are really not as I
expected [ __ ] spectacular day you know
my mama she always told me uh
southerners get our good manners from
the British I was thanking thanks out of
pity y'all and keeping out myself
[Music]
golly never heard of knocking for you in
it well I actually we had an invitation
didn't we yeah how did you know yeah
yeah it came in the shape of a bottle
we're from the Kingsmen tailor shop in
London maybe you follow us oh the
Kingsmen yeah huh that's where y'all
goddamn spine suits and them fancy
spectacles y'all got on exactly what's
right
garlic dams y'all let me see if I got it
right here
you want me to believe that it's normal
for a tailor a hack doing advanced
biometric security system with nothing
but a little bitty old watch on
I drunk that dog don't hunt what you
going to get down on your knees and tell
me who you really work for
you
[Music]
I saw in you what someone once saw and
in a minute my name is poppy Adams CEO
of the Golden Circle we engage in an
aggressive business strategy
invest in the latest technology and take
strict disciplinary action I'm speaking
to you today because our world leaders
have let us all down so we are coming
out of the shadows and taking over to
make sure no one gets in our way
Kingsman and crumpets what we supposed
to do now it's gone save the world
absolutely
[Music]
don't
spectacularly
yeah it is
[Music]
we're from the Kingsmen tailor shop in
London maybe you've heard of us
today marks the beginning of a new age
but I'm gonna show you to the Kingsmen
carnival a bit of us say the world
situation here
welcome to States me is your American
cousins we'll be working side by side
let's get started
we've got brains skills skipping rope
[Music]
to lasso whatever
[Music]
[Music]
it's very American yeah it is
[Music]
manners maketh man do you know what that
means so I see what do you do I work for
Kingsman the tailors - I must say you
are really not as I expected
[Music]
yes welcome back
welcome to stageman independent
intelligence agency your American
cousins how can I help it if I say the
world situation here
say goodbye to the Kingsmen if all of
the doomsday protocol let's get started
[Music]
[Music]
gotta make you want to slap your mama
right there boy brains skills
skipping-rope
it's a lasso whatever
[Music]
I saw in you what someone once saw in a
minute in a minute
[Music]
my name is poppy Adams CEO of the Golden
Circle we engage in an aggressive
business strategy
invest in the latest technology and take
strict disciplinary action
[Music]
I'm speaking to you today because our
world leaders have led us all down so we
are coming out of the shadows and taking
over and to make sure no one gets in our
way
Kingsman hands Krampus
[Music]
because you're friends of mine
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]